well I think for somebody who's starting
out in photography I think I think the
first thing to really begin to think of
us if you're really serious about you
know trying to progress beyond just a
casual happy snapper from time to time
and trying to get that great shot I
think you know trying to come up with
something that interests you kind of
something that can be visual and can be
more than one picture that I think you
know with today's ease of taking
pictures in digital you know it's not
that hard to come up with a
great-looking shot no matter what you're
interested in so if you want to put it
up animals you're going to photograph
flowers we want to photograph trees or
if you want to photograph your friends
you know if you do it long and hard
enough you're going to come up with some
some cool images of that and I don't
think that's really you know where the
strength of good photography lay I think
that ultimately it is about editing it
is about knowing oneself and and trying
to listen to that kind of intuitive
forces that allow you to kind of respond
more more positively and more excitedly
to one image and or to one subject over
another and to pay attention to that to
that emotion and to follow that and then
also to be aware of it when you see it
in the kind of plethora of images out
there in the world there's nothing wrong
to say when an image really hits you
like wow that's an amazing picture and
and it's something that you aspired to
to be able to kind of make that kind of
image well you know cut it out of the
magazine or you know copy it onto your
onto a file in your computer and even
once in a while if it's really important
print it out and stick a pin it on your
wall so it reminds you every day when
you go by what is it about this picture
I think you learn about pictures in
yourself by being true two things that
you personally respond to and and that's
really about I think
the only way you're going to find your
way to an original voice that isn't full
of cliches and it isn't just trying to
do what other people do but by following
your own instincts using your own
autobiography as a kind of a guide to
what things might be interesting for you
to photograph things in your life that
you've seen that you might want to then
go back and visually try and put a story
around it is it I think it's a good
place to start but not to think in the
world as a singular oh I got a great
shot but it's like how do I make a group
of images that together are more
meaningful than any one of them
separated and even when they're
separated they're still strong images
each and they're in their own right but
as a group that you can become stronger
so I think thinking in terms of larger
groupings of images then and then your
intentions are not no longer a question
you're you're now working and thinking
so it's it's kind of like being a writer
you can you know come away with a good
paragraph or a couple of good lines but
you want to create the story you want to
have a little bit more meat to the to
the narrative and that only happens when
you keep plugging away at an idea